I can't tell the difference
my week in life and dreams
the voice
in your head
it devours you
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
marvel moon knight trailer video with oscar
isaac there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs here i'll explain what's going on
because there's all kinds of big crossover
and stuff that they're setting up with a
darker marvel hearts of darkness like
midnight sun's team up down the road
this also ties in with what we just saw in
the eternals post credit scene so i'll give
a spoiler warning when i start talking about that
but if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i will be doing
videos for all the episodes when they get released
just like all the other marvel disney plus series
i'll explain what's going on with that too because
it seems like marvel has changed the order that
all these shows are coming out in but in the
trailer you hear oscar isaac as a couple different
versions of moon knight's different personalities
a lot of people joke about him being marvel's
version of batman just because of a lot of the
tropes of the character but he's quite different
he's very different from batman you probably
noticed oscar isaac changing his accent a couple
times in the trailer that's to represent when he's
changing between different personalities like he
goes from this really weird meek accent to full-on
batman voice really guttural to represent when
he switched to his full moon knight personality
i can't tell the difference between my waking life
and dreams the voice in your head it devours you
that's what he means when he says i can't tell
the difference between my waking life and dreams
now he might be marc spector when he's speaking
is that voice or he might be the jake lockley
persona the millionaire philanthropist personality
there's really like three different main moon
knight personalities but there's actually a fourth
more recently and there's an easter egg for that
fourth personality later in the trailer when he's
dressed in the white suit with the white gloves
and that is not the moon knight costume that's a
different costume from his full-blown superhero
costume that you see in a different part of the
trailer but when he's speaking those lines you see
him inside this egyptian museum exhibit staring
at multiple reflections as if he's seeing the
different personalities all in the glass the main
alternate versions are marc spector moon knight
stephen grant and jake lockley steven grant is
like the millionaire philanthropist personality
like when bruce wayne in batman movies is out
pretending to be a socialite just hanging out with
celebrities and models are you the ballerina for
the moscow valet jake lockley is sort of like the
matches malone personality he's a cab driver he's
way more violent and he has a much thicker new
york accent moon knight uses his personality as a
sort of information gatherer just because people
are much more likely to reveal things to jake
lockley than they are to someone dressed like moon
knight or dress like steven grant dressed like a
millionaire one of the big differences between him
and batman though is that batman always knows
when he's batman or bruce wayne like he knows
when he's pretending to be bruce wayne no this is
an act marc spector moon knight does not know the
difference he doesn't know who the main version of
his personality is he doesn't know if moon knight
is the main version of himself he doesn't know if
mark spector is he doesn't know if jake lockley or
steven grant is the main version like you see him
standing here in the middle of the street without
his costume on just dressed like a normal person
and it seems like he's just beaten the crap out
of a bunch of criminals and he kind of blinks as
if he's changed between personalities and doesn't
realize what just happened like wait a minute
what happened to all these people why are they
lying on the ground the gold statue in the case
that he's also staring at here in this exhibit
is of amun ra konchu's father so the whole idea is
that marc spector moon knight gets his powers from
konshu the moon god except konchu really isn't
the moon god he's a bit of a trickster in that way
so the pantheon of gods that kanshu and his
family come from present themselves as if
they're the regular egyptian pantheon but really
they're secretly just the elder gods it's the
same group of gods that catholic comes from the
person who wrote the darkhold they're much much
older than the egyptian pantheon and when earth's
culture just rose up eventually they just sort of
inserted themselves into egyptian culture and
presented themselves to the ancient egyptians
as their gods so even though khanshu and his
family are pretending to be egyptian gods all
their relationships within their pantheon are true
like kanchu was born to two different god parents
he gives mark spectre the opportunity to become
his avatar on earth and gives him all his powers
but the idea is kanchu is constantly talking
to him in his head that's what he means when he
says later in the trailer the voice in your
head it devours you the voice in your head
it devours you it's the voice of konchu that's
kind of devouring him so it's kind of a sinister
connotation to it like kanju does give him all
these powers and pretend to be a noble god like
here you can be a superhero but kanchu is a very
selfish very fickle god he will always do what is
in the best interest of konshu it'll just order
mark spector to go around and help him accomplish
all these goals but while that's happening mark
spector does actively try to use his powers for
the betterment of society like he does try to be a
superhero he's just a very very violent very crazy
superhero but the whole idea is that konchu has
this rivalry with his father amun ra and i think
that ethan hawke who's playing the main villain of
the series that's right ethan hawke is going to be
the main villain of moon knight i believe he's
going to be playing the sun king who's sort of
the moon knight style avatar of konchu's father so
you have two different gods that are going to war
with each other in their avatars going to war with
each other oscar isaac driving all of his powers
from the moon in ethan hawk maybe playing the
sun king driving all of his powers from the sun
the reason why i think that's the case is because
ethan hawk said he based his character on a famous
cult leader in real life and in the comics sun
king forms his own cult while he's plotting
against moon knight his character is obsessed
with moon knight and then approaches almond raw
and offers to become his avatar in the official
synopsis for moon knight just reads a new glow
trotting action-adventure series featuring a
complex vigilante who suffers from dissociative
identity disorder the multiple identities who
live inside him find themselves thrust into a
deadly war of the gods against the backdrop of
modern in ancient egypt that's what i meant when
i said it's basically like a war of the gods
konchu going to war with his father amun ra the
moon god going to war with the sun god and then
the two avatars kind of warring with each other
when oscar isaac puts his hands on the glass
here he's wearing this white suit like a white
tie business suit with white gloves this is
actually an easter egg for the mr knight persona
which is like the fourth persona it's a little bit
different from the regular version of moon knight
it's like a detective offshoot of his regular moon
knight personality where he works with the local
police solving cases for them is sort of like
a world's greatest detective batman spin on the
moon knight persona when he's huddled down biting
his fingers here in front of this egyptian statue
i think this might be the statue of konchu
himself when he's inside this storage facility
he seems like he's mark spector right now but he
could be jake lockley he could be steven grant
notice the shirt he's wearing is moon knight
color theme with the white and black pattern
and this look on his face of utter disbelief or
fear makes it seem like he's seeing a vision of
konchu speaking directly to him and then his voice
changes to his moon knight voice like full-on
batman voice deep and guttural as you see him
in the full-blown moon eye costume beating the
crap out of some criminals and then running
across the night landscape then you see a much
clearer scene of him jumping across the rooftops
using his powers against the moonlit night sky
and because kanchu is the moon god or at least
he's pretending to be the moon god moon knight's
powers are tied to the phases of the moon so he's
most powerful during a full moon or during like a
full solar eclipse and he's weakest during a new
moon when it's barely visible in the night sky
i know there's all kinds of questions about
gods in the marvel universe like how powerful
is konchu compared to the asgardian pantheon
like odin thor those gods they'll explore this
concept of gods in the marvel universe way more
during thor love and thunder because gore the
god butcher will basically be going on a campaign
around the universe to kill every single god but
we'll be getting all the moon-eyed episodes
way before that you've probably heard about
all the blade crossover rumors werewolf by night
crossover rumors and now after the eternals kit
harrington black knight crossovers there have
been rumors that they're going to introduce the
blade character legit like you'll actually see him
on screen during the moon knight series at some
point but i don't know if he's going to be a big
character or it'll just be a quick cameo scene in
the finale quick spoiler warning for the eternals
movie if you have not seen it yet because we need
to talk about the post-credits scene during the
eternal's post-credits scene they set up kit
harrington's character as the next black knight
he's basically in his uncle's mansion getting
ready to take up the ebony blade and actually
become the black knight when off screen you hear a
voice say are you sure you're ready for that dane
whitman and it's mahershala ali's blade character
the reason why they would put blade in a
post-credit scene like this like why they
would connect him to black knight is probably
because we're going to see black knight crossing
over with blade either in the blade movie or some
other upcoming project but we didn't actually see
him on screen he just off screen talking to dane
whitman so the idea is that we might see him on
screen for the first time during the moon knight
series if you're not familiar with werewolf by
night because there's been all this talk about him
showing up in the series as well too marvel just
announced that they're doing a halloween special
next year on disney plus for werewolf by night
i think it'll be like a single episode maybe
or maybe like two hours or something like that
werewolf by night was just a big crossover
character with moon knight inside the classic
comics but for those of you that wanted a midnight
suns team up or a darker marvel team up it seems
like that's what they're doing with a lot of these
characters through the moon knight series picture
doctor strange doing a version of that nick fury
iron man post credit scene setting up the avengers
i'm putting together a team a dark team we just
found out the next spider-man no way home trailer
is coming out next week of course i'll do a video
for it make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that congratulations
renegade with a whole bunch of threes you're the
giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so i can get your contact details everyone click
here for my marvel she hulk trailer and easter
eggs and click here for my new spider-man no
way home toby mcguire and andrew garfield video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!